nueva ola de indultos presidenciales
para los aliados de donald trump este
miércoles previo a la navidad el
presidente de eeuu concedió la clemencia
a cerca de 30 personas entre ellos
charles kushner padre de su yerno
condenado en 2005 por evasión de
impuestos pero también formada por su
antiguo director de campaña en 2016 y su
ex asesor
rogers ton ambos estuvieron implicados
en el asunto de la interferencia rusa en
las elecciones presidenciales gracias
señor presidente gracias por darme la
oportunidad de salvar mi vida los
indultos presidenciales son habituales
en los últimos días del ejercicio del
poder pero donald trump ha elegido
conceder clemencia a su entorno
involucrado en las investigaciones en
las que él es el objetivo personal a
finales de noviembre fue el ex asesor de
seguridad nacional michael flynn quien
se había beneficiado del indulto el ex
general de 61 años se había declarado
culpable en 2017 admitiendo que había
mentido al fbi sobre su relación con un
diplomático ruso muchos acusan
de intentar encubrir a sus allegados
antes de dejar el cargo esta media es
que se trata de personas con las que
tiene una conexión personal o política
directa o con conexión para estos
últimos indultos se elevan a 50 el
número de personas a las que donald
trump ha concedido clemencia en una
semana el martes el presidente
estadounidense ya había anunciado el
indulto de los antiguos miembros de la
empresa de seguridad privada blackwater
agentes declarados culpables de asesinar
a civiles iraquíes en bagdad en 2007